one for one trade every single dissident
who wants to fly the american flag and
believes in american freedom for all of
the americans who spit on the american
flag and see it as a symbol of
repression and evil will you make that
trade
right now is it gonna be a deal is there
a deal the deal could be done
it's a deal that means it's a deal the
american left
has had a tough time condemning what's
been going on in cuba but this has been
true for for
decades and the american left has always
had a bit of a soft spot for cuba
it's just an experimental regime you see
american leftists on college campuses
wearing
t-shirts of che guevara who as i
mentioned is a mass murderer and an evil
piece of human scum
i was honored to meet one of the men who
helped capture him just
last month here in florida is a pretty
amazing experience
over at a museum for the brigade that
fought in the bay pigs
it is amazing the contrast between the
cuban protesters
and the americans who don't like the
american flag so this just struck me
forcibly
last night one of the videos that was
coming out of cuba
was protesters and you'll notice that
one of the flags that they are carrying
around is the american flag
they can see it in this photo there they
are carrying around the american flag
and this this is not a shock
okay this is it they're shouting
libertad cuba they're
they're talking about freedom and
they're carrying around american flags
because everywhere on earth that you go
where you find people who want freedom
they're not carrying the flag of the
russians
or the chinese or the swedes or the
brits or the french or the germans they
are carrying the american flag and it is
not true
merely in cuba it is true in places like
hong kong here's footage from hong kong
you'll remember just before the chinese
crushed the hong kong dissident movement
you'll recall that there were members of
the hong kong district movement and they
were carrying
the american flag that is not a shock
again
the the the rule is that if you are a
dissident who seeks freedom
america is your beacon the american flag
is your symbol
again here is the footage from just
about a year ago when hong kong
dissidents were marching in the streets
carrying the american flag
[Music]
there is a reason they are pushing the
american flag there's a reason they're
flying the american flag
again no other country has its flag
flown as a symbol of freedom
around the planet none zero zip zilch
again
from cuba to hong kong wherever
communist tyranny reigns those who stand
up to it carry the american flag not
just communist
tyranny by the way in iran when you have
dissidents who are standing up to
islamic dictatorship you will see that
protesters dissidents
refuse to step on the american flag this
is an amazing video from just a couple
of years ago where dissidents were
protesting against the iranian regime
and they were they were stepping around
the american flag the
iranian regime had painted the american
flag on the pavement and the dissidents
instead of disrespecting and walking on
the american flag decided to walk around
the american flag to demonstrate that
they were not anti-america they were
actually
pro-america i mean that's amazing stuff
right there okay the contrast between
that and the number of americans
who hate and spit on the american flag
is truly astonishing and so i have a
proposal
one for one trade every single dissident
who wants to fly the american flag and
believes in american freedom for all of
the americans who spit on the american
flag and see it as a symbol of
repression and evil
how about that will we make that trade
right now
now in reality american citizens can't
be expelled simply because they don't
like the flag because we do have freedom
of speech
but in principle the folks who are
marching in cuba for liberty right now
and flying the american flag are better
americans than the americans who stand
around spitting on the american flag and
pretending that it is a symbol of
repression and evil
you know who those people are people who
have never lived under true repression
and evil
seriously if you live under the threat
of true pressure and evil the american
flag is the symbol of liberty
if you live in america a place of
liberty we have this
ungrateful rather despicable
distaste for our own freedom we we
we've gotten so used to being fat and
lazy and rich and free
that we seem to forget that there are
people all over the planet who live like
that and that for most of human history
none of that was the rule and when you
see the contrast
between people in cuba who are risking
life and limb i mean the security
services are shooting people right now
there's video that was emerging from
cuba yesterday of the police in cuba
gunning down like firing live ammunition
according to these videos
at dissidents at protesters you can see
some of the video
we see people being arrested people
being shot at
and it's a wonderful stuff happening
over there when you see that sort of
activity
by by actual repressive regimes and then
you have
the united states the left of the united
states mainstream
going completely silent on it while
spitting on the american flag it does
tell you something
because they have been completely silent
on it the left simply has nothing to say
about the liberty of people in cuba and
by the way the people who are protesting
in cuba
would not i mean i met with many of them
many of them would not identify as
right-wing american republicans they
would not
many of them would identify i'm sure as
democrats they believe
in large social services they're not
people who nationally
who oppose naturally
for example nationalized health care
they might like nationalized health care
but what they
understand on a route level is that a
government that represses its people
and abolishes private property and cuts
against profit motive and decides that
human beings ought not have rights that
pre-exist government
will inevitably slip into tyranny that
they understand at a gut level
and meanwhile you have again the
sickening specter of americans
kneeling for the american flag while
living in the richest and freest country
in the history of the world
i promise you colin kaepernick would not
trade places with any one of these cuban
dissidents
i promise you ilhana omar would not be
trading places with any one of the
people living in hong kong right now
none of these people ever willing to put
their money where their mouth is when it
comes to ripping the united states and
talk about how evil it is
none of these folks actually believe
that the united states like i really
doubt the sincerity of many of these
folks or
if i don't doubt their sincerity i doubt
their knowledge level there's tremendous
level of ignorance
if if you never look outside the borders
of the united states it's very easy to
identify the problems of the united
states if you ever look
for five seconds outside the border of
the united states or beyond the time
period
of today what you will see is that the
vast majority of history and today in
the vast majority of countries the kind
of liberties
that we expect that we demand from our
government are not available to the vast
majority of people which is why those
people marched with our flag
while we in here in the united states
are giving millions of dollars to
athletes
who just stain the american flag and yes
flags that stand for something you know
who knows that the people who are
marching with our flag
in cuba right now at risk to their own
life and limb did you know that every
single like
creates one additional leftist here that
is just science